وافق رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه على خطه لتطوير
منظومه دفاعيه لمكافحه المنظومات النوويه
والصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه كما ذكرت
وكاله يونهاب للانباء وفي سياق متصل اعلنت
كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده انهما
تعتزمان بدء مناوره عسكريه مشتركه في وقت
لاحق من هذا الشهر بهدف تعزيز الرضع ضد
التهديدات النوويه والصاروخيه المتطوره
لكوريا الشماليه في المقابل كانت بينغ
حذرت من ان سول و واشنطن ستواجهانما
وصفتها بردود فعل قويه غير مسبوقه في حاله
المضي قدما في خطتهما لهذا العام واجراء
تدريبات مشتركه
هذا وقد
اجر فيها الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
مناورات جويه مشتركه فوق شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
قاذفه استراتيجيه امريكيه من طرازبي ون بي
الى جانب مقاتلات اف 16 واف 15 الكوريه
الجنوبيه في التدريبات الجويه المشتركه
وذكرت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه ان
المناورات تاتي بعد الاتفاق على زياده
وتيره التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه وتوسيع
نطاقها ومستواها واظهار قوه الردع مقابل
التهديدات الكوريه الشماليه حسب تعبيرها